Freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen Folge ein Tag persönlicher Koch
heute wirklich mal wieder mit einem ganz
besonderen Gast ich bin ein bisschen Fan
muss ich sagen und wir haben den lieben
Otto hier haben uns fast geküsst
gerade die Chemie stimmt Otto du bist
natürlich direkt aus Kanada gekommen
hier jetzt gerade survival Squad läuft
gerade und ich werde dich ein bisschen
verwöhnen ne damit Du noch mal ein
bisschen den Genuss von so einer schönen
ja homecooking Action kommt du hast
einen absoluten Amerika Bezug das werden
wir heute ein bisschen einfließen lassen
ich sag dir schon mal was zum Frühstück
gibt ja wir machen waffles bened schön
mit knuspr Bacon selbstgemachten Holland
und so das wird dir auf jeden Fall
gefallen und du hast gerade schon gesagt
ich sehe dein Rucksack stehen ne du hast
ja ich habe man kommt ja nicht mit
leeren Händen als Gast ich habe ein paar
Sachen mit dabei erwte überhaupt gar
nichts ich hätte das halbe Lager also
als erstes dachte ich mir ich habe deine
Sachen Utensilien gesehen ich bin so
gespannt weil ihr müsst wissen Otto
verkauft einige Sachen die ich übelst
geil findeh deshalb ich habe be erst mal
ein vernünftiges Werkzeug mitgemacht
also es wä cool wenn vorsichtig sehr
sehr
scharf n ist das ein Kukri nein oder nee
das ist quasi die das ist der Prototyp
von meiner s Machete alter Schwede den
wir da entworfen haben das aber warte
mal der echte Prototyp das echte
Prototyp ja dann kann ich das ja nicht
annehmen nee ja W sagen ich koch damit
heute B kochen wir dann damit dann
besorge ich die noch mal aber die ist
wirklich scharf okay das wird auf jeden
Fall eine Challenge damit kochen wir
heute mal ein bisschen mal was anderes
oder aber damit soll natürlich nicht
lass mal bitte ein Abo jetzt an der
Stelle und ein Like weil mit jetzt nicht
zu spaßen oh mein Gott dann ihr Barbecue
mögt das ist eine der Soßen es ist eine
Galone also ich weiß nicht für die Leute
die bisschen mehr grillen wollen
eigentlich genau das richtige e wirklich
du bist geil so habe ich noch zwei
Sachen mit einmal ich liebe auch scharf
hört ja gar nicht auf oh pass auf das
ist von einem guten Kumpel von mir der
so hotsce macht verschiedenen
schärfegreiten kling klingt so als
könnte das AUA machen also vielen vielen
Dank schon dass du überhaupt was
mitgebracht hast ich fühle mich als als
wäre heute schon Weihnachten wieder
Prototyp ist noch nicht in Deutschland
erhältlich und zwar ein Hot buffalng
Sauce von meiner Lieblingsmarke Lillis
die hab auch barbec Stores in den USA
ganz viele und also jetzt nach all dem
was du mir hier jetzt geschenkt hast wie
du mich verwöhnt hast muss ich mich ja
richtig ins Zeug legen deshalb würde ich
sagen mach's dir gemütlich ich werde
jetzt zaubern wie ich noch nie gezaubert
habe und vielen vielen Dank kann sagst
du Bescheid ja auf jeden Fall ich ruf
dich soll ich Medipack mal rausräumen
falls einer falls ich schneidet oder
sowas Medipack ja bitte ich probiere
jetzt wirklich gleich damit ein bisschen
zu kochen ich fine auch Otto ne ich
meinte ich bin bin Fan so die Videos mit
seinem Sohn und so der ist rückston ist
bisschen so ein Vorbild so ein richtig
guter Mann einfach deshalb möchte ich
mich auf jeden Fall in Form von einem
leckeren Essen oder sogar drei bei ihm
erkenntlich zeigen Baken einfach auf ein
kaltes Backblech in den kalten Ofen den
Ofen kalt lassen und hoffen dass es
irgendwann knusprig wird nee wir stellen
den Ofen jetzt an 200° oberunterhitze
und den Rest lassen wir die Zeit und
unsere Augen entscheiden weil so wird
der Bacon jedes Mal perfekt hier vorne
schmilzt schon ein ganzer Block Butter
denn wir werden später eine eigene
Holland machen aber erstmal kümmere ich
mich hier um unseren Waffelteig dafür
brauchen wir einfach erstmal unsere
trockenen Zutat ein bisschen Mehl etwas
Zucker Backpulver und Vanillezucker
außerdem noch eine kleine Prise Salz und
dann verquölen wir das ganze schon mal
und jetzt kommen die flüssigen
Bestandteile das sind einmal
geschmolzene Butter und ein ganzer
Becher Buttermilch ich habe fast die
zwei Eier vergessen die kommen noch dazu
und ebenfalls unterheben und fertig ist
unser waffelteil jetzt kommen wir zu dem
Punkt bei dem ich ein bisschen aufgeregt
bin beim Frühstück wir machen eine
Holland habe ich jetzt auch schon ein
paar mal gemacht aber es ist irgendwie
immer so ein so eine Fehlerquelle so es
ist immer ein bisschen Aufregung dabei
dafür nehmen wir uns einfach ein paar
Eier schlagen die auf trennen die dann
können wir auch schon eine große
Schüssel auf auf einen Topf mit Wasser
stellen und unsere Eier hineingeben wir
rühren das ganze jetzt und man sieht
schon es wird schön schaumig und
verdoppelt sich langsam im Volumen wenn
wir da angekommen sind dann wird's auch
schon Zeit für uns unsere Butter
hinzuzufügen ich habe nichts weiteres
hinzugefügt und wir sehen wirklich schon
das Eigelb hat sogar ein bisschen die
Farbe verändert und ist richtig schön
dick geworden und jetzt beginnt für uns
der Zeitpunkt an dem wir anfangen Butter
hinein zu träufeln die habe ich einfach
auf niedriger Hitze warm werden lassen
und während wir hier quasi Butter nach
und nach reingeben emuliert das schön
bei uns in unserer Schüssel und wir
halten eine traumhafte hollandä wenn
eure Hollandes so aussieht dann seid ihr
auf dem richtigen Weg jetzt brauchen wir
natürlich noch ein bisschen Säure drin
dafür habe ich eine Zitrone ich sehe
dich gerade so bei sen Vers white ach
übrigens ist unser Bacon auch fertig
knusprig sieht so aus aber schmeckt
nicht verbrannt ihr wisst es ja die
ersten Waffeln werden nie perfekt des
haben wir schon mal welche gebacken und
machen jetzt die Produktion für Otto
also einmal ordentlich Teig drauf hier
vorne kocht schonser Wasser für die
poschierten Eier weiter geht's mit den
poschierten Eiern und schlagen jetzt
einfach unsere Eier für die poschierten
Eier in das Sieb hinein Sinn und Zweck
dahinter ist dass wir quasi das falsche
Eiweiß vom richtigen Eiweiß trennen
wollen es gibt einen Eiweiß das beim
pchieren abfackt und es gibt einen
Eiweiß was beim pchieren genau richtig
ist wir sehen jetzt quasi dass hier ein
bisschen Eiweiß von abgeht und wenn das
einmal gut abgesiebt ist können wir es
in eine Schüssel geben jetzt bleiben die
zwei Eier quasi intakt wenn unser Wasser
kocht gehen wir einmal runter mit der
Hitze so dass das Kochen aufhört und
dann können wir auch schon einen kleinen
Strudel in unser Wasser machen ich hab
einen kleinen Schuss Essig drin und dann
können wir einfach obwohl es absolut
falsch aussieht scheinbar unsere vier
Eier einfach
hineinppen zack jetzt müssen wir einfach
ein wenig Geduld haben und
[Musik]
Vertrauen so Otto das Warten hat ein
Ende es ist doch bisschen ausgeartet und
hier
istin
Früstück das ist quasi so der Landing
Spot einmal markiert so mit dem super
mit dem X genau mega wie sieht denn das
aus also wir haben ein waffle Benedict
das heißt poschierte Eier auf einer
buttermilchwaffel alles schön
amerikanisch und dazu gibt es wenn Du
möchtest natürlich noch ein bisschen was
von der hotsus die Du mitgebracht hast
aber dann lassen uns mal probieren ich
ma erstmal ohne hier scharfe Soße aber
das sieht ja wie fluffig sind die Waffen
bitte ja klar mit Buttermilch ne du
kennst und magst es wahrscheinlich auch
als Amerika
Fan boah was eine geile Mischung vom so
leicht süßlich von der Waffe mm salzig
und auch die selber gemachte Soß und
dabei du kennst den Spaß ne also hier
probierst ein bisschen lässt nicht allzu
viel anmerken und das aufessen darf auch
ganz in Ruhe
ja die Teller sind leer das ist immer
das erste gute Zeichen wir haben sogar
noch ein paar süße Waffeln hinterher
gegessen denkt nicht dass die Gäste hier
nicht satt werden wir machen eine schöne
Portion fürs Auge und danach wird
ehrenlos gegessen das kann ich das kann
ich auf jeden Fall bestätigen also ich
hätte schon einfach wenn ich wüsste es
kommt nicht noch was gut gesagt boah da
können wir noch drei Dinger von machen
also richtig fluffig die Waffeln super
lecker so ein bisschen süß dann die
selbstgemachte Soß und ist Bacon der
natürlich mega Cross ist die Eier und
schmeckt mit beiden Varianten also mit
hotsauce und ohne hotsauce mag das ja so
ein bisschen zu Stückel hast du so
einmal die die gan und dann haben wir
noch was Süßes haben wir die ganze
Bandbreite schon mal abgedeckt zum
Frühstücken was soll ich sagen ja du
musst jetzt eine Note drunter packen und
zwar von null bis ze ja es geht ja
leider nur 10 von ze also die würde ich
dir auf jeden Fall dafür geben weil das
das hab ins Geschäft se gut super das
heißt wann machen wir das jeden Morgen
ich komm vorbei jederzeit kein Problem
immer wenn du mal wenn du mal wieder
sowas brauchst und Reset nachdem
irgendwie 5 Wochen in der Wildnis warst
kommst vorbei ma ich dir das Frühstück
ernsthaft wenn du so draußen bist so
lange dann träumst du wirklich von
solchen Dingen okay was ich damit
zurückkomme und dann hast du das
wirklich so im Kopf mega dann das gut
dann hoffe ich dass ich deine Träume
inspirieren konnte und mit dem
Mittagessen wird sich das hoffentlich
nicht ändern wir machen Buffalo Wings so
wir sind beim Mittagessen angekommen und
der Otto konnte nicht ruhig sitzen
bleiben der will einfach auch mal ein
bisschen helfen deshalb erfülle ich dir
gerne diesen Wunsch du darfst gerne mal
hier ich will mal sehen wie du dich
selbst mit deiner Machete hier
durchchlägst fang einfach schon mal an
was Grünes zu hexen jetzt will ich mal
gucken wie du hier jetzt abgehst mit
deinerete ma ist eigentlich schlech
damit ja nur Sachen durch hier aufs
Brett ja ne ne das sieht immer so
künstlerisch aus wie die Leute das so
schnippeln keine Ahnung wie klein muss
das werden was immer ein guter Trick ist
du kannst das einfach so
zerkneulen bisschen klein machen dann
kannst du einfach so zack zack zack zack
zack runterchneiden hier drüben gebe ich
in ein wenig Butter ein bisschen
gepressten Knoblauch hinein damit pimpen
wir die hotsu noch mal das wird in
Amerika gerne gemacht auch wenn man
richtig geiles Produkt hat einfach noch
mal ein bisschen mehr Butter bisschen
Knoblauch kann halt immer nur noch
besser werden ne was macht man mit
solchen großen Stückchen wird die mitk
geschnppelt oder raussortieren die
schneidet man noch kleiner aufftag
verstanden ich habe jetzt hier
Hähnchenflügel könnt ihr natürlich schon
ausgelöst kaufen wir haben einmal hier
die Flaps also mit den zwei Knochen und
einmal die Drums quasi mehr Fleisch an
einem Knochen ist und die wollen wir
jetzt einmal Teilen ich persönlich bin
ja ein riesen Fan von den Flaps also
wenn man wenn man sie bekommt nehme ich
gerne nur Flaps und dann muss man einmal
genau zwischen das Gelenk reinkommen und
runterschneiden und dann hat man sie
sauber getrennt so wie man dich jetzt
hier sieht ne in der Küche sieht man
dich glaube ich relativ selten oder
tatsächlich ja K kochst du gerne zu
Hause Grillen t ab und zu wirklich aber
gerne würde ich jetzt nicht sagen ich
bin ja auch sehr bei mir auch bei Touren
manche nehmen mit raus und köcheln da
draußen ich denke mir so ja gut ist halt
zwei Tage nichts ja okay machst halt ein
bisschen Fasten also bevor ich was zum
Köcheln mit den Wald nehme nehme ich
einfach gar nichts mit und sag noch
nicht mehr irgendeine fertig Sachen
sondern mir ja kan ma zwei Tage fasten
krass also ich bin nicht wirklich so der
köchelfritze Leute wir haben jetzt hier
die vorbereiteten Wings die trockne ich
noch mal gut ab geb sie hier in Schüssel
rein wenn die Wings dann getrocknet und
geteilt sind geben wir ein bisschen
Backpulver und ein bisschen stärker dran
und werfen die einmal gut durch so dass
sie quasi von allen Seiten benetzt sind
was wir dadurch erzielen wollen ist dass
sie quasi so ein bisschen die
Feuchtigkeit binden und die Oberfläche
getrocknet wird wir haben nur das
Problem s lange nicht so trocken wie sie
sein sollten also ab in den Kühlschrank
und da hat man natürlich dann auch auch
schon eine ordentliche vernünftige
Portion vorbereitet so sehen unsere
Wings einen Tag später aus die sind
nicht ganz so trocken wie ich es mir
gewünscht hätte aber wir werden
herausfinden ob es trotzdem funktioniert
230° Backofen einfach reinknallen und
erstmal 20 Minuten brutzeln lassen das
sieht super aus was Du hier gemacht hast
wir geben jetzt in unsere Schüssel hier
vorne einmal alles was wir für unser
Ranch Dressing brauchen das ist einmal
Mayonnaise kann man natürlich auch super
fertig kaufen ne ja allerdings aus den
USA bekommt man es meist nicht weil es
auch sehr kurzhaltbar ist auch starten
deswegen weil es halt ich glaub aufgrund
Ei und all was drin ist kann ich jetzt
z.B gar nicht importieren bwen rening am
besten nach dem Rezept von Max selber
machen hier so nämlich Crem fres
Mayonnaise Zwiebelpulver Knoblauchpulver
auch ganz beliebt in der amerikanischen
Küche ne so dies diese granulierten
zwiebeln und Knoblauch und es hat
einfach einen anderen Geschmack als das
wenn man es frisch macht es ist wirklich
einfach anders deshalb machen wir auch
beides du darfst hier einmal den hier
machen mega ich hoffe das Ding geht
nicht kaputt ich liebe ja Knoblauch ne
ja ja ich mag es auch gerne ich benutze
selten die Pressen tatsächlich damit
abkratzen oder oder mit Machete vi od
genau sieh mal das mal selbst mit so
großen das ist dann over machen wir noch
eine rein oder frischer Knoblauch ist
sehr potent also wie knoblauchig willst
haben Schlückchen Buttermilch kommt noch
dazu das rie schon super natürlich eine
biozitrone davon nehmen wir dann ein
bisschen von der zeste rein und dann
natürlich auch ein bisschen was vom
Saft und dann pressen wir einmal die
Zitrone raus und wenn wir das hier in
die Hand machen ihr kennt den Spaß B die
drin bisschen Kräuter rein du kannst
schon mal umrühren Salz darf natürlich
auch nicht fehlen das war Sache die wir
in Kanada mitgenommen haben als einziges
Lebensmittel Salzmischung und wir zwei
Sachen mit normalsalz und dingssalz weiß
schon gar nicht mehr auf jeden Fall war
das Salz hab wir mitgenommen we gesagt
hab okay komm ein Luxusartikel haben wir
so ein pötchen mit Salz Salz ist schon
was Feines ne früher war Salz ja auch
wirklich ein Luxusgegenstand genauso wie
Pfeffer selbstgemachte Rench warum habe
ich
gepustet ich okay mach ich was falsch
schmeckt wie es soll oder schmeckt wie s
soll so jetzt können wir unsere
wingssoße finalisieren will probier die
mal pur die riecht schön schön nach
Essig das macht eine gute Buffalo
wingssße aus oder generell Buffalo
wingssße aus eben neben der Schärfe auch
noch so eine Essig notote hat und die
sieht schon richtig gut aus die ist auch
so
dickflüssigcküssig D da wahrscheinlich
echt schon gut Butter auch drin
ist Feuer Bo die ist wirklich also not
bad aber mehr Butter macht alles noch
besser einfach mal ein bisschen von
unserer Soße hier dazu Bo geil ich bin
wirklich happy dass mir das mitgebracht
ich freue mich fre mich sehr darüber
jetzt hier einmal durchrüen das
verbindet sich halt sofort und wir haben
dieses strahlende orange und ich finde
das macht so eine Wings Sauce aus das
ist auch eigentlich alles was wir machen
müssen wir müssen ein bisschen auf die
Wings warten 15 Minuten dann wenden wir
die aber ansonsten können wir es uns
jetzt wieder gemütlich machen etwa 20
Minuten sind rum und wir sehen dass uns
erstmal eine Wolke von chicken Dampf
entgegenkommt heißt jetzt ist Zeit die
Wings zu wenden damit alles dann auch
beidseitig knusprig wird so Leute gucken
wir uns das einmal an die haben eine
wunderschöne goldbraune Farbe bekommen
hier oben drauf die Haut ist knusprig
sie hätte noch trockener sein können
wahrscheinlich h wir beim vor Iten die
Wings bisschen besser abtrocknen können
weil die die jetzt im Kühlschrank sind
sehen richtig gut aus aber wir coaten
das jetzt sowieso mit der Wings Sauce
das he wir haben diesen kleinen Crunch
der bleibt und die Wings sind einfach
super aus also geben wir jetzt die Wings
einfach in eine große Schüssel fettig
knusprig man hört's richtig und jetzt
beginnt die Wings Magie so wir tossen
die Wings ein bisschen durch und
parallel Tropfen wir die Buffalo hot
saauce dazu und so entstehen dann die
allerechten Buffalo wings es gibt nicht
zu viel schauen wir mal was Otto dazu
sagt Otto ja du hast glaube ich Buffalo
Wings bestellt oder ja
allerdings sieht aus wie in Amerika das
hier und das hier werden wir brauchen
eine Sache hole ich noch ich glaube die
Sauce ist auf jeden Fall schon gut
scharfah Mega Man das zieht schon so
richtig nach ob das zieht richtig in die
Nase rein ne die Essig Schärfe die
müssen ehrlich du musst dabei auch
schwitzen bei sowas ja ja also sch ich
glaube wir können jetzt einfach jegliche
Zivilisiertheit hinter uns lassen und
einfach einsteigen also wir kann
natürlich jetzt hier ne so fürs fürs
Alibi fürs gewissen bind diese celery
Sticks mit Rench Sel ma Rench Dressing
genau bist du ein Mann für die Flaps
oder für die Drums ich bin da sind wir
wier dabei für beides okay echt alles
ich liebe die Flaps wir haben wirklich
also die sind wunderschön bedeckt
umseitig von der gesamten hot saauce und
dann geht's ganz
einfach oh ja m Bo eine schöne Schärfe
mhm das ist wirklich ein festm also es
ist eine Schande tut mir eigentlich auch
was leid dass ich euch das so zeige weil
diese hotwing sauces diese Buffalo
sauces mit essic sind schwer zu bekommen
deshalb wenn ihr es nachmacht vielleicht
rüht ihr euch noch eine hotsce mit ein
bisschen Essig an oder sowas dann kriegt
man da vielleicht was raus vielleicht
machen wir auch mal ein tiktok oder ein
Youtube SH wie man Wings Sauce macht wir
kämpfen uns hier mal ein bisschen durch
unsere Platte durch und dann sehen wir
uns gleich zur Bewertung wieder wir
schwitzen der Mund brennt aber wir sind
glücklich ehrlich so muss das sein ja
und alle die mit denen ich echt näher
bin die wissen ich esse es nicht oft
also meist so zwei dreimal im Jahr ja
halt dann in den USA und dann vermiss
ich das dann hier aber das hat mich
gerade zurückgeführt also hätte ich
Augen zugemacht ich gesagt Minen starten
nein noch besser tatsächlich also
saglich das sch mir weil macht was macht
dies Gericht aus die Schärfe ja und
denkst so boah und dann man muss dazu
sagen den Hauptcharakter die wingsource
hast du halt auch mitgebracht ne
verfeiner genau wir haben sie noch mal
verfeinert so das ist glaube ich auch so
ein Geheimtrick immer noch mal Butter
dran immer noch mal Knoblauch dran aber
geschmacklich war war das eine ze von ze
voll deswegen wenn du mich fragst am
Rating kann ich auch nur das sagen das
wirklich also ich komme Nachhinein das
mir zu spät eingefallen ich GU bei dem
Rench Dressing noch blue Chees dazu
getan ja einf noch mal so noch mal ein
extra Kick dazu aber so ist das einfach
die es ist die perfekte Mischung weil du
hast dieses scharfe BAM du denkst okay
ich muss mir mit Z Ruhe kommen und dann
hast du diesen frisches Rench Dressing
und neutralisiert wieder also was soll
ich sagen ze von ze ich ich ich feier
aber ich fand das hier auch einfach
unfassbar lecker die Kohlenhydrat haben
aber gefehlt deshalb machen wir jetzt
eine schöne Pasta und zwar mit frischen
Steinpilzen aus dem Wald wir haben die
ganze Zeit überlegt wie können wir
diesem Outdoor Thema irgendwie
kulinarisch gerecht werden das war meine
beste Antwort einfach was mit Pilzen
kochen ist auch geil schön saisonal
regional wir machen Frische taliatelle
und dazu eine Steinpilz panchetta
Charlotten Sahne Weißwein jetzt habe ich
alle Zutaten gesagt Soße so nennen wir
sie nein wir fangen aber an indem wir
die Pasta machen weil dann haben wir die
erledigt haben das aus den Händen ihr
wisst Leute Pasta ich lieb es einfach
neen wir schön Eier in die Mitte vier
Stück 400 g Mehl ein wenig Olivenöl eine
kleine Prise Salz und dann können wir
auch schon anfangen die Eier zu verquüen
es ist einfach eine Sache die wird nicht
alt Pasta frisch machen Pasta selbst
machen das macht einfach immer und immer
wieder Spaß und es lohnt sich auch immer
und immer wieder weil es ist einfach ein
Unterschied ob man frische Pasta ist
oder getrocknete Pasta und jetzt kneten
wir das so lange durch bis unser Teig
gleichmäßig mit Feuchtigkeit versorgt
ist der Teig ist schön zusammengekommen
Decken ih einmal schön ab so für 20
Minuten und können in der Zeit schon mal
uns an die Arbeit machen und hier ein
bisschen schnibbeln die Challenge nehme
ich an so auf nebenbei machen wir
einfach alles mit einer maete kümmern
wir uns jetzt um die Pasta der Teig hat
ein bisschen geruht ma 200 pro Schritt
der Teig ist wirklich einfacher könnte
nicht sein ein Ei 100 g Mehl was mehr
musst du nicht ma machst ein bisschen
Salz rein bisschen Olivenöl rein aber
das ist alles das ist das Geheimnis
itener so einfach geht gute Pasta
ja ich dachte das ist jetzt hier keine
Ahnung was da für geheime Zutaten
durchgemacht werden und vielleicht doch
schade dass du jetzt hier in der Küche
stehst sonst hätte ich g gedacht hab
hier eine Pasta selbst g nein es ist
natürlich klar ein bisschen Arbeit aber
eine Arbeit die sich definitiv lohnt und
dann wechselt man den Aufsatz jetzt
haben wir ein taliatella Aufsatz und
dann gehen wir die Pasta einfach rein
jetzt passiert die magieotto unten kommt
die Pasta raus das macht einfach Spaß
sich anzuschauen ist ja auch schön oder
genau ich fin manche Dinge sind einfach
irgendwie beruhigend anzuschauen oder so
satisfying sag man so schön oder genau
ja und Pasta machen gehört auf jeden
Fall dazu und wie gesagt dann ordentlich
Mehl dazu paar Mal durchwerfen es ist
wirklich verboten einfach eine schöne
frische Pasta zu machen so Freunde Pilze
werden geschnitten Schneid die schön
grob die ziehen sich natürlich ein
bisschen zusammen das hier wissen nicht
alle über Pilze man kann Pilze komplett
ohne Öl anbraten was ist der Vorteil
davon na die haben so viel Wasser dass
erstmal das Wasser austritt und Pilze
sind ja wie Schwämme das heißt wenn du
mit Öl dran gehst dann saugen die das Öl
einfach auf das heißt wenn du so ein
bisschen röstarom dran bekommen willst
was wir natürlich wollen jetzt d
jach das am besten ganz ohne Flüssigkeit
und spter gehen mit weiweinös das ab und
dannöst sich auch das was so panenboden
klebt was okay weil ich mir ger schon so
okay passiert aber gut das geht absolut
gut auf jeden Fall stehen e aus 90% nur
Wasser genau ja deshalb was ist so das
das krasseste was du Einsätze
eingeschlossen dir mal so auf der in der
Feldküche oder so mal gekocht hast oder
hast du das einfach wirklich komplett
außen vorgelassen und du in der Bundes
deine deine deine Einmann Ration ja die
sind ja kulinarisch jetzt deutlich
besser geworden die letzten Jahre
tatsächlich aber ich hat mal auf einem
leerrgang wo es haben am Anfang des
leergangs bekommenen Hasen Forelle
Kartoffel Möhre Zwiebel mussten quasi
damit so ja nicht ganz zwei Wochen
überleben mus selber was ich
Bee genau Fisch habe ich sofort gegessen
weil den kannst nicht lange haltbar
machen da hat ich auf dieser fluchtphase
tatsächlich dann so so salzblock im Wald
gefunden fürs Rotwild damit ein Stück
Salz raus gemeißelt und fzerkrippe für
Schweine mir so wildschweinfutter ach
was ja gut das ist dann auch erlaubt ne
so wie du bei S wild Panama Nut Müll
benutzen kannst das ist Hal die Realität
Realität nimmst das was du finden kannst
und wenn es irgendwas ist was da halt
rumfliegt ich gebe ein bisschen
panchetta dazu bisschen grob geschnitten
wir wollen so ein bisschen so diesen
diesen roughen Look einfach hinbekommen
für das ganze Gericht und was wir jetzt
hier am Pfannenboden haben ist gar nicht
schlimm also dass ich da ein bisschen
was absetzt weil wie gesagt wir löschen
eh gleich großzügig mit Weißwein ab es
wird eine richtig leckere Angelegenheit
jetzt gehen wir auch mal Knoblauch und
schlotten dazu und was soll der Geiz ne
ich liebe Olivenöl ja das ist
so wenn man so Outdoor kocht ne machst
du ja weniger aber so die keine Ahnung
bei bei bei Fritz habe ich das glaube
ich gesehen dann hat man auch mal so ein
Dutch auf und sowas ne ja ich weiß
machen ganz viele sind ja wirklich auch
autdoor verbinden halt mit auch mal
kochen so ne vielleicht ist es ja hast
du mich hier auf de Trichter gebracht
vielleicht könnt ihr mal zusammen im wei
Kochen oh hätte ich bock drauf auf jeden
Fall ich sorg für das schöne Lager und
alles und Feuer und und vielleicht auch
für das was wir kochen noch ein letztes
Mal ablöschen
so und dann können wir auch runtergehen
mit der Hitze und unsere Sahne angießen
unsere Soße ist jetzt quasi fertig
reduziert ein bisschen ein das heißt wir
kochen die Nudeln und verbinden das
[Musik]
ganze jeder Tag hat ein Ende auch dieser
wunderschöne und hier endet er mit einer
frischen Pasta mit Steinpilzen
und Weißwein sahnensoße so hab erstmal
richtig gesehen wie Pasta selbst gemacht
wird ja siehst du was neues gelernt so
ich hoffe ziehen nicht den ganzen Ärger
der Italienerin als ichgen Löffel meinst
du ich hoffe das geht durch also bitte
Entschuldigung Liebe italienischen
Freunde schön cremig so eine leichte
Bitternote hat man ne schmeckst du sie
ja könn mir vorstellen kommt davon dass
ich die Pilch ein bisschen sehr sehr
hart rangenommen habe aber wir werden
sehen ob und wie sich das auf die
Bewertung auswirkt wir sehen uns gleich
wieder mir gut geschmeckt sehr
gut richtig geile Sache finde ich wenn
man sich vorstellt man kann einfach da
rausgehen in den Wald man sammelt diese
Pilze und in paar Minuten kocht man sich
diesen Teller jetzt zusammen so das ist
Hal das hat irgendwie sowas
ursprüngliches finde ich so Pilze
sammeln Nudeln kochen fertig ja generell
mit so Lebensmitteln aus der Natur
einfach zu wissen ich kann da wirklich
müssen Supermarkt gehen manche Sachen
die Steinpilze h man sammeln können ja
das stimmt wir haben sie auf dem Markt
geholt icht unser
Fehler was sagst du wie hat dir
geschmeckt richtig gut ich muss sagen
diese Bissfestigkeit Italiener aldente
also perfekt wirklich aldente mit meiner
bescheidenen Meinung aber wirklich
dieses leicht bistfest trotzdem war ich
dazu Soße mega cremig ich mag den
durchgesmack Geschmack vom schmeck
natürlich weißwe schmeckst Pilze richtig
gut du hast gesagt die sind so ist so
ein bisschen bitter kleine Bitternote
hat es vielleicht s meine
geschmacksrezepturen da nicht aber es
war jetzt auch wirklich also ich bin
sehr selbstkritisch ich hab es auch mit
mit Genuss gegessen also es war so da
war so eine Nuance die habe ich glaube
ich davon gehabt dass ich die Pilze
wirklich in die Hölle geschickt habe so
auf allerhöchster Stufe durch
durchgeballert aber was gibt's in dem
ganzen null bis ze also ich würde ja
eigentlich wieder sagen im müs es müsste
eine 10 von Zeeh sein jetzt haben wir
kein tiramu oder so aber kennst nicht
wenn du Nudeln sowas typisch italienisch
und danach so das muss eigentlich schon
sein leider kann ich damit nicht dienen
ich habe leider nichts parat ich ma Eis
nein ich glaube ich ma eine 9,9 von 10
dann kann auch keiner sagen dass du
immer nur Z genau das auch weil im Herz
hatürch 10 V ze verdient wir machen 9,9
du musst gar nicht mehr sagen du musst
gar nicht mehr sagen ich freue mich sehr
du warst ein wundervoller Gast vielen
Dank für die lieben Mitbringsel es hat
sehr Spaß gemacht für dich zu kochen und
wer weiß vielleicht entführst du mich
auch mal in deine Welt find ich super
vielen Dank wirklich für die Einladung
super interessant das auch mal so zu
sehen von der Seite und ja danke für die
Zeit das war richtig lecker mega cool
wie gesagt vielleicht machen wir irgendw
eine Fortsetzung davor im bald ich sorge
für ein behagliches zu Hause und du
Lagerfeuer könnt ihr mal in die comies
schreiben ob ihr das sehen wollt bis zum
nächsten Video Ciao
CIA